hey guys hello who is here but you guys
might remember when ro and I did the
Starbucks challenge video wasn't that be
like the best thing ever it was amazing
delicious we had so much fun so we
actually are doing a round two we
partnered with Starbucks to be able to
make this happen and I can't believe it
I can't believe it it's like a dream
come true I love Starbucks I grew up in
Seattle I lived there for about 23 years
he's like such a coffee culture has a
very strong coffee culture and it is
home of the original Starbucks I've been
there I've been there that's why we get
along you've been there she knows every
time I see the Starbucks it just reminds
me of Seattle it reminds me of home it
reminds me of happiness yeah exactly
that's where all I know happiest she is
back there preparing our coffees because
we have no idea what kind of coffee
we're gonna be drinking cuz we're doing
the other challenge so we are gonna be
tasting ten different flavors but we
can't know what they are can you show
them what's back there can you show them
what's back okay okay good luck good
luck oh look my parents cookie cookie
were you back here what is it what did
you see something did you see something
oh the copies oh my goodness I can't
wait this is like my birthday I just
have one Starbucks a day maybe a couple
of weeks
daddy wants to play a stupid Pig do you
want to play the game oh yeah I'm gonna
raise you up there let's chew up booze
booze Oh are we going ten again ten
drinks yeah do we get to drink them all
afterward yeah
we do and we have lots of blindfolds to
choose from Wow cute ones like last time
you remember last time we had little
pink eyelashes and then when you came
over to the piece of challenge we had
the Lapine so I've been adventuring out
since our last challenge and trying
different things so usually like once a
week I will go and I'll be like I'm
gonna try something different off the
menu cuz usually I just get like a basic
black coffee or now it's pumpkin spice
latte season so clearly quite excited
about it
oh right for this guy's look how cute
your little bear it looks just like
cookie isn't they're very relaxing
Justine I apologize because they're a
little bit heavy Oh like a nice little
ice they already I can feel the gel in
there oh go look at you my little baby
boo oh not quite nice try woman I love
berries - I have a hard time
differentiating between them when they
are in drink form I think that there's
very berries in here I started growing
them in house grassy knoll berry berries
you're growing a very day what color is
it
hey we just did our first one and I was
laughing so hard that I started crying
underneath my mask and then I had like
mascara all over my face we're doing
makeup removal over here first I gotta
fix my eyelashes like stick and gonna
salt me to see oh oh I definitely did
yeah I was laughing so hard I was crying
the best part of this challenge is like
never ending Starbucks I mean it'll end
after 10:00 but like that's a lot this
is the most Starbucks okay this is the
second time that I've had the both
Starbucks in one day but it feels
amazing I'm ready for that next one mate
oh I have a really great sense of
Starbucks smell oh so like I'm smelling
it I'm like I think I already know what
this is how do you do it you just just
nips I just shove my nose in there the
warm drink
oh I'm smell Oh
Oh instead of going out and doing a wine
tasting day can we go out and do a
coffee taste I mean we're kind of doing
a coffee tasting day right now but I
want to line up a cold brew with the
regular one we're going to do it after
this I mean why don't ya let me do the
carbon challenge we go to Starbucks we
actually should
so where's our bags right now I just had
my mind blown
so I didn't even know that Starbucks now
has almond milk and during our taste
test challenge I'm not gonna tell you
which one it was and you'll see in the
video this is B almond almond pumpkin
spice latte so it's basically a pumpkin
spice latte with almond milk yep hmm
it's a new thing it almost threw us off
because adobe like wait a minute this
tastes like the classic fall drink comes
out that PSL it tastes like that but it
tastes a little different taste is
different
they now have almond milk amazing cuz I
try it I was like this smells exactly
like the PSL I can smell the nutmeg and
I can smell our cinnamon I can smell
some clothes
hashtag almond milk because if do you
think they have a different hashtag for
it
almond milk hello almond milk PSL hey
you know um I shagged a P so I'm not
sure what number we on it we're gonna be
doing our fifth point now it's six five
five five five girl on to the next one
drink number six
mmm building another or hotter wait
here's hot yeah it shows a lot my school
yeah
hey nice this roof briefed us up so with
Adam on with this other I have
absolutely no idea even what this is it
was dying to you and I taste a hint of
salt you want to taste mine yeah
wait we have the same dream it's just oh
wait a minute yeah you got forgot yours
is cool here do is yours right okay okay
I'm drinking out here oh my goodness it
tastes really good cold too is this the
same drink you're after taste the spices
are stronger but ha chilly mocha I like
a little sprinkle of I'm not sure what
that is that's ash we get a nice big mix
yeah girl let's get in there what kind
of spices my palate isn't very advanced
we just finished the challenge there are
so many drinks we're going to get all of
the drinks so we're gonna line them up
to show you guys how many we taste
tested today because it's a lot
[Music]
oh look at all those drink nothing guys
couldn't see it through this lens I just
thought you might want to see it again
through the monitor it looks oh yeah
look he's excited
I can even know how to even try to get
these all in a suit shocked it give it
even gonna be possible this looks like
we're hosting a starbucks party yeah
everyone's invited so your eyes are
gonna have to go watch the final
challenge on Rose channel so I'll put a
link in the description everything will
be down there so go look I also put it
on a card so if you guys just click
somewhere whichever side it happens to
be on and are you gonna dance I was
trying to video bomb you the whole time
I was just like this so spoiler alert
there were three drinks that we tried
they were off their fall menus so
there's two that I had never tried and
they were so so good - the chili mocha
he's probably our favorite it comes in
two different ways you can get it as a
Frappuccino or you can get it as a hot
coffee hot or cold but guess what we
liked it the best - you have to find out
his secret and also for fall of course
they have their PSL which is a pumpkin
spice latte always a seasonal favorite
and the last one that we tried that was
brand new that I had never tried before
I've had their cold brew coffee but this
was a vanilla sweet cream cold brew it
was good I didn't know you guys that
cold brew was a thing yeah it's a thing
they brew it all cold and I believe we
looked up to the it brews for 20 hours
in the fridge before they actually serve
it so that's people never heat it it's
actually cool and it actually tastes it
I know surprising we need to take you
and try these side by side cold brew and
iced coffee because if there is a
difference well guys thank you so much
for watching be sure to go check out the
video on Rose Channel it's the challenge
video it's incredible it's part two
because we did this before as you guys
remember and that's all they talked
about is how much they'll argue I teach
watch me did you
well thank you guys so much for watching
let me know what your favorite Starbucks
drink is and especially those fall
favorites so go try those new ones the
chili mocha definitely recommend it all
right I'm gonna go because I'm feeling
really really excited all of our drinks
okay guys
[Music]